صدق شوف صديقي
الفنان
لا شك مغمس بالسياسي يفترض ولا يمكن ان
يكون بمعزل عن الحدث السياسي المحيط فيه
والعلاقه بين الفن والسياسي على قضيه لكن
نحن نتحرك انا عن حالي اتحدث نتحرك
بالمعنى الوطني وليس بالمعنى السياسي نحن
على مسافه واحده بمعنى
الشعب السوري بالنسبه لنا هو شعب سوري
واحد نحن نتصدى حتى بمواضيعنا الان لكل
الصعوبات الاقتصاديه
خدميه
المعاشيه التي نواجهها نحاول
ان
يعني نطالب ونشتغل على اعاده احساس المطلق
والانتماء لان هذه الارض هي ارضي وان هذا
الوطن عندما يحترق هو بيتي نحن خرجنا بقول
لك اياها بصراحه انا عن حالي خرجنا خارج
الاصطفاف السياسي محمود الذي همم دفع ثمنه
الجميع في الحروب لا احد ينتصر صحيح لا
احد ينتصر في الحروب اذا فكرنا فكلنا
مهزومون في اي حرب في الدنيا لكن موقف
الفنان ان يبقى على مسافه وطنيه من
الاشياء ان يبقى همم على مسافه يعني كيف
بدي اقول لك على المستوى الوطني دون ان
يدخل في قراءات اصطفافيه لما يحدث